I as I recall it took me about seven
weeks to brainstorm and figure out what
the rules were and what I wanted the
main characters to be in the story and
the flow of the story and how I wanted
it all to come out and after I figured
that out then I just sat down and wrote
it and that took me about three or four
days
I had written one screenplay already and
had sold it and and that was the the sum
total of my Hollywood experience up till
then I'd gone to a lot of meetings and
my agent had pretty much said you really
need to write something else and get it
out there quickly before people tire of
you and I had had this thought and I
decided you know what I could write that
one quickly that's a really good one I
could it's a little movie i can write it
quickly and get it out there and use it
as a writing sample just to show people
when I walk in the room here's here's my
latest script so that was the the
purpose of it and then I after it went
out I got a ton of meetings off of it
because people like the store and they
like the writing and I counted 50
different meetings and that's what
really got me my feet wet in Hollywood I
got to see a lot meet a lot of these
producers I got a couple of jobs off of
it nobody wanted to make Groundhog Day
in fact kind of strangely I was new to
LA and I was going to these meetings and
people would say ah Danny glad to meet
you I loved Groundhog Day of course we
can't make it and I am saying of course
and and nobody ever explained to me why
and I didn't ask why not because I was
trying to just go along get along who
accept the industry on its own terms and
and they'd say well but what else have
you got her we've got this list of ideas
if you like any of those and then I got
a couple of jobs and I was on my way and
it wasn't until my agent quit to become
a schoolteacher and that I found myself
without an agent but I had this spec
script that I was sending around to try
and get a new agent and that's how that
script wound up at CAA with Richard love
it uh he called me and said I love
Groundhog Day of course we can't
represent you and I said of course he
said but I have a client who I think
might like this could I give it to him
and he sent it to Harold Ramis and
that's how the movie got set up
well one thing that occurred to me as I
wanted to do something fun with the
movie and the first thing I thought was
you know what I don't want to have to
deal with how he got into this situation
I don't want to deal with a some kind of
supernatural reason that he was stuck in
the same day because then the movie
becomes about the plot of his getting
out from under it instead of about the
that existential quality of how does he
just deal with it and so I thought why
know how I can avoid that I'll start in
the middle the first thing that happens
is you hear the clock radio come on with
the i got you babe and then the djs come
on doing their little stick and phil is
able to sort of mouthed the words to
what they're saying when he wakes up
before he even knows what they're saying
and the audience is thinking huh that's
strange how does he know what's playing
on the radio and he goes downstairs and
he knows what mrs. Lancaster's going to
say before she says it so he's
anticipating and the audience is
thinking wow this is weird how does this
guy know what's going to happen before
it happens then it goes outside and this
geeky GEICO's Phil and Phil goes up to
him and takes off his glove and he slugs
him and we have no idea why that
happened and so I set it up by beginning
in the middle with his mystery how does
this guy have this supernatural ability
and we go through meeting you know going
through the groundhog report and setting
up the day and then he repeats the day
and that's when we know how the movie is
set up and we understand how he knows
what he knows that was the the way I set
it up and from the very beginning they
were the studio was a little antsy about
that Harold Ramis the director said that
he he liked that he tried to keep it but
eventually there was just this weight of
convention where they really wanted to
just establish who he is set it up and
then have this thing happened when he
starts repeating the day and so I'd say
that was the biggest thing that changed
was when when the movie opened the
beginning of it and also as part of
having the movie started
middle I had a voice over Phil had a
voice over sort of leading the audience
along so they wouldn't feel too
disrupted or too disoriented and kind of
helping them bond with Phil and as soon
as we straightened out the the timeline
to where it began a little sooner that
became unnecessary so on the face of it
the very two biggest changes were that
it began sooner before the repetition
and that there is no voiceover